all right welcome everybody a
very very busy day we're standing by for
what are just about the last 10 or 15
minutes of debate in the house of
representatives
in anticipation of a vote uh on
impeachment for president donald trump
if donald trump is impeached today he
would be this
only the first president ever he would
be only the first president he would be
the first president
um to be impeached two times
uh let's see here i'm being told that my
go live notification is outdated i
apologize i'm managing a lot of things
here and trying to get them
all of these elements fixed um so we are
just moments and i am told that the
house will be going
directly into a vote because of the
virus
the vote takes place in a slightly uh
spaced out way
so that the vote itself could take 45 to
60 minutes
and for everybody saying he won't be
impeached he will be impeached he may
not be convicted
please guys we're going through this the
second time let's not do this again
the first impeachment i would report he
got impeached and people would come in
and say david he didn't get impeached
they're not going to impeach him and i
would say they
impeached him that they didn't convict
it's a trial in the senate come on guys
we can't get this it's sort of like you
know maslow's hierarchy of needs
where you can't become self-actualized
unless like you have shelter and stuff
we can't have any more sophisticated
discussion
if people still say people still don't
know the difference between the
impeachment and the trial so we're
please guys please please this is the
this is the vote on impeachment
he will be impeached or not in the house
it will then be up to the senate to
try the impeachment all right guys i'm
i'm begging i'm literally begging people
i i i am supplicating here
uh okay let's just take a brief listen
and i've got a bunch of different things
to do after as well thing was gentlelady
from uh michigan
uh mr claib the gentlewoman from
michigan is recognized for 30 seconds
thank you madam chair and michigan's
13th
all right so they're continuing we're
watching msnbc where we also see a shot
and so far things are as far as i know
relatively calm we also have our
c-span feed and we have multiple feeds
ready to go
should anything happen to our primary
feed but so far all of these different
um uh layers of uh security
at the u.s capitol and things relatively
calm
as far as i know as far as i know at um
at this point in time um
okay what else do we have going oh okay
um
one of the main arguments that we've
been hearing from republicans in the
house
but also just like random republicans on
tv
is that impeachment would be divisive
and so it shouldn't be done and oh hold
on is this over
and the gentleman from new york has
three and three quarter minutes
remaining
from ohio has four okay
and the gentleman from ohio is
recognized
thank you so we have seven minutes total
between the two of them that puts us at
3
32 and then you know maybe another
couple minutes as they delegate back and
forth
so one of the arguments that's being
made and it's a terrible argument is
it would be divisive to impeach trump a
second time and as i've said you all
know my position at this point i won't
beat you over the head with it we'll
drop the ban hammer
but i'm not going to hammer you with
this impeachment is a responsibility you
don't say
what would the impact be how would
people re
did the president do something
impeachable if the answer is yes which
even many republicans conceded then you
have to impeach
but there's an even crazier argument
that's been been made and i'm going to
play it for you here
this is bro whoa what what an appearance
this is brian
kilmeade from fox news and his argument
is impeachment could make trumpists v be
violent
take a listen to this believe that
america could be more effective and has
been ineffective because we've been at
each other's throats
what could be more disenchanting they
don't want to be around again they don't
want him to run again
they don't want him to run again that's
fine but you don't understand too
there's a lot of people that want him to
number one
continue to be a force in the republican
party believe a lot what he believes
he has 75 million supporters so if you
have an overarching sense that i got to
bring the country together
because we see what's happening around
this country how 50 state houses are
being
threatened on inauguration day this is
the last thing you want to do
this is the don't impeach because state
houses are being threatened by the very
people incited by trump
for which you want to impeach him
astounds me
that now chuck schumer guys is exploring
it
this is this is saying negotiate with
terrorists yeah i hope people understand
this
what what by and by the way what does
this say about trumpists that he says
as a response to congress doing what
they are constitutionally
uh uh allowed to do and i believe must
do trumpus will be violent
that is called negotiating with
terrorists you will be violent
so therefore don't do the thing even if
it's the right thing to do
what what brian kilmeade should instead
be saying hey guys
um this entire thing was idiocy
trump lied to you for two months and got
you to go completely bonkers
and commit acts of violence don't fall
for it again
because more of you will get arrested
but instead brian kilmeade says i don't
know trumpus might get violent if if
trump is impeached
so therefore don't do it it's it's
saying negotiate with terrorists the
very people who
always say don't negotiate with
terrorists are now saying no no you
should you should change what you do
because the terrorists might get violent
if you do this thing it's absolutely
nuts
absolutely nuts um okay
we are stan we have probably about four
to six minutes of debate left
the debate i don't find to be
particularly interesting it's just
basically
members of congress taking turns saying
why i will or won't vote to impeach
trump
but very soon we're going to get to the
vote we're also monitoring what's going
on in dc around the capital very heavy
military presence national guard
and it looks like so far things are
things are relatively calm there's one
other point and mega alpha
is making this point on twitch they're
actually going to be violent either way
if trump leaves they're going to be
violent is the belief right now among
law enforcement um
they they they are going to be violent
if trump is impeached they're going to
be violent if trump is removed by the
25th
they're going to be violent if joe biden
is inaugurated there they will be
violent either way so we
we are better served communicating
reality
not allowing them to hold the
proceedings of the house of
representatives hostage
um and continuing forward with what must
happen that's that's essentially
where we are and what needs to be uh
let's see has trump rubbed off on you
with delay to your own stream
uh yes exactly i was late today because
since trump's late all the time now i
want to be late as well
um big thank you to grandmaster benjamin
feingold who is now a
four-month subscriber via twitch that's
huge that's absolutely huge
um very much appreciate that and
actually along those lines
i want to say thanks to the seven people
who just grabbed twitch subscriptions
on our twitch stream i also want to say
thank you
to kayla titus kayla titus
has signed up at joinpackman.com
coming in out of nowhere with a
discounted membership
and uh very much appreciate that
we are actually today is today is an
historic day
um can you believe when i interviewed
someone from the dictionary
i actually said is it a historic or
an historic and they actually said it's
really either
but anyway i find it funny to say and
historic
and i don't even know why it's funny i
think it's correct it's an historic day
for
two reasons we may see donald trump
uh impeached for this uh as the for the
second time he would be the first
president ever to do so
and we may see the david pakman show
youtube channel hit 1.25 million
subscribers today
which is insane let's listen the
gentleman reserves
madison speaker and now you're 30
seconds to the gentlelady from
texas miss jackson lane the gentlewoman
from texas is
recognized for 30 seconds sheila jackson
lee we will be hearing from but we won't
actually i
i don't you know okay um we're just kind
of monitoring what's going on here
and um in any case it's it's going to be
an historic day an historic day
in a number of different ways the far
right is always calling for a civil war
has anyone asked them what that would
entail it's not like you can tell by
looking who's a democrat or republican
they just want to be terrorists
yeah i have a i have a segment from
uh this past friday about whether a
civil war would be plausible and of
course at this point
you really have an urban rural divide
where even in red states
the cities tend to be blue or at least
purple and
it would be very difficult to even
figure out like what would be the two
sides and much more likely would be some
kind of militia type thing where you see
militias versus the government within
states
than a sort of union versus confederacy
type of situation but
of course let's hope that this doesn't
happen let's hope that that
uh that that is not what happens some
believe biden can bring unity by
pardoning trump what are your thoughts
biden should not pardon trump biden [ __ ]
absolutely
not pardon donald trump republican wept
the gentleman from louisiana mr scalise
the gentleman from louisiana another
going to steve scalise a complete and
total bomb thrower
um okay a few other bits of news that
you might find interesting
interesting camp auschwitz guy has been
arrested by the fbi
whoa hold on a second this is a very
very exciting arrest
and um this was one of the people that
uh we've been keeping an eye on
and he indeed has now been arrested so
that is
great news and we're going to continue
uh seeing these arrests happen
also you may or may not have heard but
one of the people one of the prominent
terrorists arrested
is apparently refusing to eat because
they're not serving him
organic food in jail i know that that
sounds crazy but hold on a second
capital riot organic food guy
let me see here yeah here i know it
sounds like a complete and total joke
and people are going nuts yeah this this
is this is real
uh hold on a second where where is this
oh that is not it capital riot organic
food yeah the
it's the shaman very strange name
here we go let's take a look at it
uh oh and i have to turn off my ad
blocker for man it is just
crazy it's like i put the ad blocker on
at everybody's request
because they were getting annoyed by ads
and now i have to turn it off people
are mocking oh my god can you see this
garbage
it's like i can only see it's a quarter
of the screen
people are mocking capital riot detainee
q shaman for refusing to eat non-organic
jail food because he gets very sick and
a dietitian agreed it doesn't add up
um jake angeli a far-right conspiracy
theorist from arizona known as q shaman
stormed the capital
he's been arrested blah blah blah blah
blah at his federal hearing his mother
said he hadn't eaten in custody since
friday due to his strict diet he gets
very sick if he doesn't eat organic food
he needs to eat
okay so anyway very very big
disagreements
as to the standpoint of organic and then
you know they they were actually then
arguing
is anything really organic because
between acid rain and
and air pollution what is organic these
days you know
that's a joke they were not really
arguing that in court but
they might as well have been they might
as well have been
uh okay real
quick um i did get another voicemail
from
troy york this time calling as his black
character jamal jenkins yesterday we
heard from him as ramon ramos
which is his hispanic character
and a new character named dmitry
diamond anyway here he called as jamal
jenkins let's just take a quick listen
to that
sister maul jenkins from university park
illinois
and i'm calling the david pakman show
from university park illinois to say
that
the united states needs another election
right this election was stolen by the
democrat party
and we need to have another election
without the tactic of the
mail-in voting fraudulent tactic that
the democrat
tactic that's interesting christ abused
this has been a dishonest financial
republic election
and the mainstream media is complicit
with this coup attempt against president
trump
president trump needs to stay in office
can you imagine thinking the coup
attempt was against
trump i mean that is that is uh that is
something else
that is really something else troy york
also reportedly on a hunger strike he's
refusing to eat organic food he's doing
the opposite hunger strike as the q guy
troy york will only eat non-organic food
okay big thank you to anthony marvel for
the join pacman.com subscription
sebastian diwo as well as chris ware
which puts us at 11. we're standing by
imminently and urgently
for a vote on impeachment it would be an
historic day we have never seen a
president impeach two times
i also of course want to say thanks
to the 15 twitch subscribers who just
signed up
this is steny hoyer the majority leader
let's listen
conference said it was
she said the president of the united
states
summoned the mob
assembled the mob all right so steny
hoyer very slowly and deliberately
explaining to us why he supports
impeachment um jamal swift coming in via
super chat says hey homie i'm the real
jamal
yeah jamal jenkins is
is a imaginary person it's really a
right-wing nut named troy york
jamal swift who has been in the chat for
for at this point i think years
uh is the real jamal that we deal with
on
on this program rusty says isn't
everything organic on an atomic level
that's a fair question
that's a fair question marin
ron and roningen from norway says i
follow american politics the way
americans follow keeping up with the
kardashians well no that's not true a
lot of americans follow keeping up with
the kardashians not at all
so if you're following politics you're
already not like them but i get what
you're pointing out about
the entertainment aspect of it or the
rubbernecking car crash
aspect of it um in terms of oh do we
have do we have some trolls
in the chat uh i'm being advised that
there are some pretty serious trolls
over on twitch yeah let's look into that
moderators please let's keep an eye on
that
people asking about vaccination we are
so
slowly approaching 10 million doses
given we are at 9.94 million
it's so embarrassing what's going on
with these vaccines
um and by the way i've a bunch of a
bunch of friends
of mine i could go and get a vaccine
tomorrow if i wanted
i'm not even gonna get into what it is
that could be done i'm not gonna do it
because it would be wrong
um but the at this point
this entire thing is so mismanaged that
vaccines aren't even going into people's
arms vaccines are
on the edge of spoiling because they're
being defrosted and then no one's
showing up
and at the same time anyone in a sense
anyone who wants a vaccine can get one
in a bunch of different states and i'm
not even i'm not even going to go into
it it's just
crazy what what anyone could do right
now i could go tomorrow and get a
vaccine
i'm not going to say in which state um
because of the
the the miss han the miss handling is
leading both to
anyone being able to get one but nobody
actually getting one
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous the
other thing is that now
because they are counting doses now
they've started giving second doses so
of the 9.94 million
how many were first doses how many were
second doses how many people have been
vaccinated
we don't know it's it's crazy it's crazy
what's going on right now
uh all right other super chats coming in
david pakman show chemistry makes a
distinction between organic and
inorganic compounds love the show
yeah but the definition of an organic
food is an
f that's an fda designation that's not
the same as the
chemistry definition of organic and
inorganic compounds two totally
different things
uh trump promised he'd run everything
like his business and he delivered he
invested a ton of money and effort only
to lose the presidency the house and the
senate well
very much so very much so does
insurrection require
a plan and objective and leaders this is
a really good question
and one of the things that we're going
to see is that
inevitably many of the people arrested
and charged with sedition
um it's not they're not going to go down
for sedition because the definition of
sedition
impli includes intent and a bunch of
attorneys emailed me about this and they
said
david any good lawyer will get all but
the absolute
worst of the rioters off on sedition
because you need much like perjury it
goes to intent and what one's intentions
are
um and we will be talking more about
that and we talked about it on today's
program as well thanks david for all you
do you're helping me and my girlfriend
get through this madness appreciate it
thank you
uh very much appreciate that if you're
just joining us
we are expecting a vote any moment
we this seems to be getting to the very
very end this is steny hoyer and he may
be rapping let's listen
of the duty of the president united
states in history
are we to stand silent will we stand
silent will we not stand up
and say this
is not acceptable madam speaker for four
years donald trump has made no effort to
hide his ambitions
or his lacking of republican principles
not our principles but the principles
that abraham lincoln was just quoted as
having said
your president our president
has never displayed those in the four
years he's been president united states
he's getting down to the very final
minutes and expecting to move
directly into a vote on impeachment and
we're going to be here
with you it is
completely conceivable that at the same
time
that donald trump is impeached a second
time
our youtube channel will hit 1.25
million subscribers and if i were to ask
you which one of those two milestones is
more important
there would be not a single doubt in the
audience not a single doubt in the
audience whatsoever
there is every indication that if donald
trump is impeached today
that the trial won't happen a well into
or at least
until joe biden's presidency uh the
senate is
out right now and uh apparently mitch
mcconnell has already said it's not
going to be coming back before
january by or before january 19th of
course joe biden
will be inaugurated on the 20th so this
is an impeachment trial
that is going to be taking place
under a joe biden presidency remember
i'm still seeing people confused in the
chat
the house votes on impeachment if the
house votes to impeach
trump is impeached separately
the senate holds a trial and votes to
convict
or to acquit we will know today whether
the president
is impeached we won't know for some
period of time
whether the president is convicted all
right remember these are two different
oh my god people in the chat again with
trump isn't going to be impeached
oh dear god i worry for the country
i worry for the country big thank you to
the
seven people who just signed up
via twitch putting us at 33
i also want to thank some people who
grabbed memberships on my website
joinedpakman.com michael workmeister
casper christensen bizzad
and sarinajad abraham
bordes mark weaver
and gear skuttleberg wow
am i having trouble with names today but
that is six folks who just signed up
and uh i really do appreciate that ben
barringer says at least one of the
writers was on
active duty called in sick with kovid
true
to attend the riot in fatigues arrested
upon return to base i haven't heard that
but that's a good thing
if the house vote for impeachment was
anonymous how many republicans do you
think would vote to impeach
more than six that's for sure
i'll subscribe right now if you tell me
what you would call mcconnell if there
are no repercussions
spanish with an argentinian accent is
preferred oh no i had a freudian slip
it's [ __ ] mcconnell i i had a very
strong freudian
i would even call it a freudian slide
people who are familiar with gary
larson's the far
side will will recognize that joke from
25 years ago
uh no i once accidentally it was
actually freudian in nature
uh freudian and convalescent in nature i
i called him [ __ ] mcconnell
let me see if i can actually find that
gary larson
far side freudian slide this is one i
remember this from when i was a kid this
is
for whatever reason this really cracks
me up check this out
uh oh here it is it's on pinterest
i don't know why i remember this i used
to read the far side when i was a kid
oh my god this is horrible what is going
on i can't even see this
look at that look at this website
pinterest you can't see a damn thing
anyway here it is this is freudian slide
i love this see freud's sliding into
home base anyway
we're back and we're off of that a lot
of people very very angry with me for
even showing that
okay do you think in the style of trump
has plans
to sell us secrets to the highest bidder
to north korea or russia and do you
think he has real slash
forge dirt on pence so he won't enact
25th amendment
uh second part i don't know i think
trump won't
sell secrets but i think trump might
inadvertently
uh give them out as he's done before
moscow mitch do you think lefleur gates
or others were aiding the terrorists
during the siege i don't know
there have been a number of claims about
um
we heard from ayanna presley that the
panic buttons were removed from the
house
i don't know if that's true it's an
allegation that's been made
james clyburn said that somehow even
though he
works at an unmarked office and he has a
marked office
that the insurrectionists went right to
the unmarked office which he finds
suspicious
i don't know the answer there's a lot of
assertions that have been made
and i don't i simply don't know the
truth of the truth of that it's the type
of thing that's going to have to be uh
going to have to be investigated jimmy
says love the show been watching for
over a year i like your commentary and
your program keeps me informed hopefully
the news becomes less crazy
soon georgia counties must certify
1-5 election by 114 i think if georgia
who were attacked by trump certifies can
schumer call the senate back for trial
monday a.m
no apparently it's uh if from what i
read
mitch mcconnell has a way of preventing
the senate from being called back for
the impeachment trial if indeed there's
going to be one
and uh the impeachment trial as a result
will not happen
until uh joe biden is president
from from the latest news that i've seen
okay
if you're just joining us it should only
be a few more minutes until the vote
starts let's listen to what's going on
steny hoy are still going reject
deceit reject fear mongering
reject sedition tyranny
and insurrection reject the demand for
fealty to one man over fidelity
to one's country when i addressed the
house during the debate over the
articles of impeachment in december 2019
i said the following
we need not ask who will be the first to
show our courage
by standing up to president trump hmm
the question we must ask
who will be the last to find it
senator mcconnell representative cheney
a number of other representatives who
have spoken on this floor with great
courage
madam speaker
because there is much fear of donald
trump
there's much fear of donald trump's
tweets this is a
fear of donald trump this is an absolute
clinic on how to properly wear a mask
the nose uh clip combined with i mean
it's just it's perfectly
sized he is projecting beautifully
and the mask is just in place why why
can't everybody understand how to wear a
mask
i hope others will be honest with
themselves and with their constituents
as liz cheney was saying there has never
been a greater portrayal by a president
united states of his office
and his oath to the constitution don't
dismiss that
she's the daughter of a vice president
united states right
who was the whip when i came to congress
as she has taken a stand i hope others
will as well
madam speaker soon
the clerk will call the roll please get
on with it
and ask for our votes make no mistake
this will be no ordinary roll call
this is about our country our
constitution
and our democracy these votes will be
inscribed on the role of history
a record of courage and of our
commitment to country and constitution
of our commitment to the rule of law and
renewal of that which we inherited
and hope to pass on unbroken
unshattered with just seven days left in
the president's term
this vote is not about timing
it is about principle
and fidelity to our constitution
it concerns the clear and present danger
facing our country
not only in these final days of the
trump administration
but in the weeks months and years that
will follow
it is about the necessity to demonstrate
to this generation
and to future generations the duty we
share to protect our democracy
every single day
do not pretend my friends that it was
simply those
who okay so steny hoyer still going
still going and going and going and
eventually we will get to a vote
uh on impeachment we are we're slowly
um painfully getting in that direction
i see a couple people asked what i'm
reading right now i just finished
up the kim stanley robinson california
trilogy these are
three books written over a period of
about uh
six or eight years um different
versions of future usas all taking place
in california
really really good um some better than i
don't the first one i didn't love but
the other two
great i'm also reading from the
standpoint of non-fiction the book
homicide by
is it i believe it's david simon it's
the guy who eventually created the show
the wire
and it's a book from the early 90s he
spent
um some time with baltimore homicide
and uh it is it is fascinating i mean
what you learn about
homicide investigation um questioning of
of
murder suspects and a lot of different
things really really interesting um
really interesting book um very much
enjoying it that's what i'm reading
right now and then i've got
i got a jack womack book i've never read
any of his stuff
um it's called ambient
can't really tell you if it's any good
yet because uh
i'm just i'm just starting it david some
of my republican family members still
believe that
cue anon crap and post endlessly about
it do you think there is any end in
sight probably not for them eventually i
think they'll kind of
uh tire themselves out hopefully david
says with the joint chief statement the
dcag speech and today's announcement of
the gao looking into members who gave
recon tours to the mob
you would think republican leaders quell
their members from acting out further
yeah they don't care they don't care
a handful of spineless people will vote
present
yeah i cannot stand people who say
wearing a mask is in any way bad for
them
i have to wear full face masks up in the
attics that get upwards of 130
fahrenheit
my dad has been doing it 25 years yeah
remember early on when there were people
saying that the mask
made it so you got not enough oxygen and
too much carbon dioxide
remember that that was that was crazy
that was absolutely nuts
uh i i'm not hearing much of that at
this point
all right let's see if we're moving on
house resolution 41
the previous question is ordered on the
resolution
the question is on adoption of the
resolution
those in favor say aye
those the poles say no in the opinion of
the chair of the
eyes have it the gentleman from ohio
is recognized for that reason thank you
madam speaker we'd ask for a roll call
vote
pursuant to section 3 s of house
resolution 8
the yeas and nays are ordered members
will record their votes by an electronic
device
so now the voting will start and we will
see on screen 53
whoa okay uh we will see on screen what
it is that's going on i guess we can we
can do it here
um and uh so
now some of you may or may not know this
but because of uh
covid the virus etc
um even though it is normally a
15-minute vote i believe they extend to
an
hour congresswoman aoc explained this
yesterday on twitter so even when the
time expires and you see all zeros
there will still be no votes ready to go
if you're not used to the way that this
looks
it's kind of backwards you start on this
right column which is
no vote haven't voted yet those are all
the people who have yet to vote so that
number is going to decline as they vote
and then you will see these no votes
move over to either yay
nay or president now as you can see
every democrat
vote so far every democratic vote
every democrat has voted yay so far
and three republicans have voted yay it
is 67 to 63
and we are somewhere between oh hold on
what's going on now strickland of
washington pursuant to hres eight
i informed the house that ms strickland
will vote yes on hres 24.
oh okay it seems that they are uh
delivering some of the votes by voice to
them
to then be counted and as you can see um
about 120 530 people voted very quickly
but we are now kind of stuck at 301
ready to go and they are going to be
doing this process where they
some of these votes are going to be
announced one by one they are proxy
votes
proxy votes that's the term that i was
looking for so we
are standing by and watching this
happen potentially a historic day
potentially an historic day we will see
theoret oh donna edwards i've
interviewed her she's great um
we will see the second uh the second
impeachment of donald trump
for the first time ever 73 to 66.
and the votes continue to come in
continue to come in
david hope all is well my friend keep up
the good work impeach trump
this scene is very familiar to last
night's voting
how can the gop decry that democrats are
trying to divide the country
after all they did to do the same talk
about hypocrisy absolutely insane
david i got into an argument with a
jesse lee peterson follower and my god
it was just like your conversation with
jesse
keep up the good work yeah
not uh not not an exercise
in anything other than futility that is
for sure
um okay more votes being recorded by
proxy oh sorry i've fallen way behind on
thank yous
i do want to thank the 13 folks who just
grabbed
subscriptions via twitch i really
appreciate that
and also a bunch of people signing up on
my website i want to say thanks to tom
chapini and mary bishop
as well as justin frund
and we are now at 55 yes
yes the coupon code works we are
primarily funded
by these website memberships consider
yourself
i'm humbly inviting you on this historic
day to grab a membership at
joinpakman.com
pay full price if you want or don't
use the coupon code better21 the
discount is so big on advice of council
i'm not even telling you how big it is
i'm just saying
massive discount uh we used to publish
the percentage it got dicey
legally the ag took a little too much of
an interest in our discounts
so now we're just saying it's massive
it's a massive discount okay better 21
is the code
as we continue to see the votes tallied
here
what are my thoughts on jeffrey rosen
posting his response to the capital
attack on youtube as an unlisted video
haven't seen it
unfortunately i haven't seen it i would
not be able to comment on that
any consequences for the plague
spreading maskless republicans who
infected everyone while sheltering in
place i would consider tarring and
feathering
yet there are a whole bunch of democrats
who now have tested positive for the
virus after having to shelter in place
on insurrection day
with massless republicans who refuse to
wear masks
it's it's toxic it's toxic
as you can see the votes are
accumulating four
republicans four republicans have now
voted
to impeach donald trump
a party-line vote other than those four
were aware of six were aware of six
republicans who expressed that they
would be
uh voting for impeachment today
and we are expecting to have the results
somewhere between 10
and 50 10 and 50 minutes from now
a lot of proxy votes as a result of the
virus
and so that's what you see happening as
people come to the
lecterns to announce votes let's listen
to a couple of them
uh 264 members remaining
oh it's seven republicans now okay
that's good
here we're going to hear one i believe
or not i don't know
okay maybe not
i'll keep an eye on it so it's basically
just an announcement that
uh congressman or congresswoman
so-and-so is voting yay or nay and then
it's
oh here we go madam speaker as the
member designated by mr carson pursuant
to hres eight
i informed the house that mr carson will
vote yes on hres24
there you go so those are the proxy
votes
and even though it says only eight
minutes and 45 seconds left to go
we expect it to take longer as a result
of the
proxy voting okay i was blown away
when i saw what a powerful discount i
received when i signed up with better 21
as my coupon code wow
that's brandon kaiser of kaiser roll
fame
um and brandon has privately confided
that originally
the kaiser role was conceived as a very
different type of bread
but uh due to a conflict the kaiser role
that we see today is what uh his family
ended up with
that's a joke by the way that's not true
um
oh there's our friend hakeem jeffries
he's been on the program before very
good guy congressman from new york
um and he is delivering a proxy vote
which is very exciting
the discounts are tremendous breeze
breathes deeply through teeth yes
olympus has fallen sure made it look
harder
to storm the capitol building than it
was
right david can you do a current segment
on uyghurs
yes i would do that i would do that
um mike says could you please explain
the
i uh eyes nose shouting bs the ai's nays
how the hell can someone honestly say
the eyes seem to have it on how loud it
was screamed
yeah so here's the thing you you may
have noticed that they said
uh everybody voted voting yes say i and
you heard a noise
everybody everybody voting and then you
heard it and it sort of to us sounded
quite similar in volume
it's this is one of those situations
where a lot of this stuff is perfunctory
and performative
they know what the vote is on
impeachment because this is such a big
deal basically everybody
most of the members have already said
how they plan to vote
um and so the chair knows
that that is the way it went so that's
how they report it
and then jim jordan says i would like a
roll call vote because we aren't sure
it's just all perfunctory and
performative but uh yeah i know what
you're saying like it didn't really
sound very much louder for the yeses
than the nose
that's absolutely uh that that's that's
absolutely true but that's the way it is
that's the way they do it and that's
that's the way it is
dear david i'm not a vowel sincerely
h okay yeah i don't know what that's
about
um let's see what's happening over on uh
on msnbc
these are the same figures who have
menacing words for people who carry out
acts uh in the name of international
terrorism but when they're domestic
terrorists
who happen to be supported by some
members of their own base
um they're very very very afraid of
speaking the truth and
and end up being brave to put it bluntly
also along uh watching with us dan
goldman
who was instrumental in the first
impeachment effort i think it was
exactly a year ago
dan goldman your thoughts i feel like so
many of the
roots okay so we're waiting on the last
215
votes on the second impeachment of
donald trump and we are expecting
uh that in the next five to 45 minutes
we are going to know the results and
that's very important
uh did you see the threat to the
republic tier list you're on
no that's interesting can somebody tell
me where to find that threat to the
republic tier list
let's see threat to the republic
tier list david pakman
let's see no
i i i have no idea who did that
david thanks for all you do found you a
few months ago did you watch jordan
klepper's piece from the riots just
posted yesterday no i want to see that
though uh jordan clepper does some good
stuff
just use the coupon code on
joinpakman.com and the absolutely
obscene
savings crashed my personal computer
instantly yeah if you're on a
on an apple computer don't even think
about using the coupon code apples do
not have the power to handle that
discount code
that's also a joke by the way okay
um i always love your book
recommendations ever thought of starting
a book club
segment i have not we used to do more
book stuff on the show it didn't do very
well
didn't do very well what do you think
trump is doing and feeling right now
no idea he's probably trying to figure
out how to borrow someone's twitter
account
oliver says genuinely curious how many
hours per day or books per week do you
read i'm jealous i don't get to read as
much as i'd like
you know i'll usually read like 20
minutes in the morning when i first get
up just to just to do it before the day
gets ahead of me
and then a little bit in the evening and
then i'll read fiction before going to
bed so i mean it's probably
you know 20 20 i'm probably reading like
50 to 60 minutes a day
that that's my thought he's referring to
an historic day not understanding h
is not a vowel an historic day okay
man every that was people are really
fired up and distracted by that that's
crazy
that's wild a big thank you to the
eight people who just signed up via
twitch
i appreciate that and then i also
appreciate everybody
signing up on my website and
unfortunately because it's so many
people i'm not going to be able to
thank everybody right now one two three
four five six seven
uh wow 43
43 people just signed up on my website
putting us at um 106.
that is a crazy number um but i
that that's that's amazing we are down
below 200 votes left to be cast
five republicans so far have voted
for the second impeachment
of donald trump which would make this
the first president ever to be impeached
two times two prior impeachments
remember that
um we never act that uh donald trump
uh unlike richard nixon was impeached
nixon was not impeached and part of the
reason that nixon was not impeached
is that republicans went to him and they
said it's over
they said you've you've got to go
because we will convict you we will
impeach you and we will convict you
and richard nixon avoided impeachment
but did resign uh donald trump
impeached once already and potentially a
second time
uh about two-thirds of the members of
the house have voted this is house
resolution 24.
uh remember that this is sort of
backwards you want to start on the right
column we have 168 people who have not
yet voted
133 have voted to impeach 133 have voted
not to now
because we know that democrats have a
majority and we know that
i'm told seven republicans as the sixth
comes in
seven republicans plan to vote yay um
this is all but a foregone conclusion
that donald trump is going to be
impeached a second time uh minutes from
now
minutes from now proud lincoln
wyomingite who paid full price for
subscription and have no regrets
that's a pretty big shot across the bow
at everybody taking advantage of the
coupon code
that's really aggressive i think the
discount on the website to subscribe
was way too much of a discount so i'll
give more
greetings from richmond virginia thanks
jesse
would it be wrong to call this
impeachment to electric boogaloo i think
it would be wrong yeah
what are your thoughts on how the courts
will rule on trump's potential
self-pardon
that's way above my pay grade um i've
read a number of uh
opinions from legal experts about a
self-pardon and the bottom line is it's
not been tested in court
i i don't even know whether it's worth
going beyond that i mean i i've given on
the show a bunch of times now
uh justifications for why a self pardon
would be okay
and justifications for why it would not
but ultimately the point is it's not
been tested in court and we won't really
know
until if and until it is
i'm sorry david david it was just an
joke
apology accepted apology accepted
david is there any chance in heck that
trump will actually be convicted
percentage guests i'm not even getting
i'm not even
uh commenting on that yet it's going to
be under joe biden's presidency and
democratic control of the senate
we just have to wait we just have to
wait i think it's an uphill battle for
sure
how darren says how about doing reaction
videos to newsmax oan clips we'd love to
see you dismantling those networks on a
weekly basis
yeah yeah we we've actually talked about
that i think that
right-wing media is going to you know
this is actually kind of a side story
but
about nine ten months ago i started
getting messages from some people in the
audience
saying you know it's a little bit
overboard
to say that it is weaponized
what we are seeing from right wing media
but if january 6
proved anything it's that disinformation
right-wing propaganda
is absolutely been weaponized and that
has a real effect
so yeah i expect right-wing media to be
off the wall crazy for the next two
years at least
and there's going to be no no shortage
of it
henna baked ham says via twitch sub oh
my god david do you even look at twitch
thanks for being our guide through these
historical times yeah some of you may or
may not know the inside joke but
at some point someone on twitch
asks whether i even pay attention to
twitch
and of course i do of course i do we are
down to just the last 130 130
members of the house left to vote and we
are
very very close to donald trump being
impeached for a second time
very close jacob coming in with a
brutally powerful hundred dollar super
chat
says and historic is correct anne is
used before the vowel sound not just
before a vowel
letter since david doesn't use use the h
sound
instead using the pronunciation that
drops it he is right to use an
you know the truth is i'm not saying
historic
i'm just kind of blending it together
and historic
and historic so uh
why are we even talking about that
that's my fault
that's my fault um
there is this is a choice right now if
you put newsmax or oan as a highlight on
your stream instead of a sideshow you
were promoting them no more capitulation
whoa that's a big admonishment there
keep my fingers crossed for you usa
greetings from germany
did you see the video of the police
officer crushed in the riots the fact
that 149 republicans voted nay is
disturbing
of course it is of course it is
uh here's another comment on my grammar
the phrase an historic day comes from
the common accent practice of dropping
h's
if you drop the h the first sound of
historic
is a vowel yikes
this could actually take the show down
i'm
worried that this is the end of the show
we now have a plus
five for yays over nays now plus six
with just 118 members left to vote on
the impeachment
of donald trump and uh it look people
are about to completely destroy
twitch and my website i do want to say
thank you
to an additional nine twitch subscribers
that puts us at 115 um
and as far as the website goes
an additional oh my god hold on a second
could this be true an additional
28 people just grabbed website
memberships putting us at 143.
um
is there a vote amount they need to
reach an
actual impeachment yes let's calculate
it
okay let's calculate it we're going to
do this right now
uh hold on a second
okay there's 435 people in the house all
right so you need a majority
so you divide by two you get 217.5 now
you can't have half a vote so it's got
to be 218.
can anybody confirm 218 is my does my
math check out
218 or okay very good
218 is the number my friends and uh
currently at 167 with 102
members left to vote and certainly
if you get some present votes that can
cause a problem
that can very much cause a problem i
don't expect an
issue i don't expect an
issue uh
okay under a hundred now i started
watching about a month or two ago thanks
for all the hard work the savings for
the website means needs a surgeon
general's warning
absolutely that's why it's a union
not an union
and union a union you that's interest
that's an interesting one i've not
thought about that
hi from london america has become a
laughingstock i know
i know i i know you're right
what can i say it just is what it is
um we are down to the last 91
91 votes on the impeachment of donald
john trump
the sequel covid 45
the impeachment of donald jump john
trump part two
uh maybe a fair way to describe it at
this point
um other things
oh yeah let me mention oh this is
important so uh
yesterday on the program i interviewed
daniel
lombroso about his documentary white
white noise he embedded himself with the
alt-right
and i am i'm almost done watching it i
rented it on amazon prime video
absolutely fantastic so if you guys
missed that interview we just uploaded
it an hour or two ago
it is very much worth watching he embeds
himself with richard spencer
mike cernovich and
lauren southern and i encourage you to
watch it it's really
really good white noise white noise
white noise is the name of it just
google
white noise the documentary you'll find
it just signed up with a coupon code and
it's a crime how low this is it is a war
crime we want only peaceful prices
yikes okay are you going to have
va'ash on again soon maybe
i don't know uh we'll see
michael traeger kuzman says is there a
way to get notified when you go live i
don't know the answer to that to be
honest
youtube eliminated email notification i
believe that you can get push
notifications
for either twitch or youtube so i guess
your phone would ding when i go live
i believe people in the chat can
probably
yeah hit the bell oh and by the way yeah
i mentioned this earlier
we are oh my god we are 230 youtube
subscribers away from hitting one and a
quarter million
it feels like just yesterday we hit 1
million
we are down to our last 223
and we will be 250
000 youtube subscribers
beyond a million which is insane we have
55
55 million 55 000
people watching on youtube right now
let's do it
we can do this thing right now let's end
it
just end it put an end to this insanity
did you see trump and theresa may
holding hands his hands are really tiny
i did i don't i didn't see that
greetings from czech republic love your
show hope your country eventually
recovers from trumpism i hope so too
i hope so too um
we're down to the end yeah let's listen
a little bit to what is what is
happening
people are getting antsy that biden won
but the majority of them are from
districts that donald trump won some by
a very large margin including
liz cheney so these are votes of
principle
these are people who are thinking about
their country and not their next
election
and um i i give them a lot of credit i'm
i'm mad at all of them for not standing
up to this president
sooner right and putting up with his
line but
these are votes of courage today and now
we're up to eight um claire stay with us
dan goldman also
standing by with us dan i wonder if you
can just speak from the perspective
of an impeachment manager about um
what is sort of an unexpected vote so
we're down to
impeachment it feels like 23 votes to go
and donald john trump will be impeached
a second time
something that has never ever happened
218 is the number
we are at 195. 218 minus oh 197. we are
now
only 21 21 votes away
it is getting really really close
ever heard of double jeopardy that's
this no uh double jeopardy applies to
the same
same wrongdoing
same wrongdoing because there are vacant
seats you only need 217 that's
i believe that that's right yeah i
apologize because of the vacant seats
it's 217 we are 18
away 18 away from
uh from impeachment number two david
long time fan and member
from the lewis and natandes do you have
any plans to make more long-form videos
in 2021
absolutely many plans
coupon code fresh chart would
work for me might want to look into that
uh darn i really wanted to listen to the
boner show yeah that that coupon code is
done
the coupon code is better 20 better 21.
it's anne as in pedantic why is there no
secret vote
those are the rules uh can
trump be held legally liable for crimes
after impeachment incitement finance
report having too small of hands
yes to all of the above yes to all of
the above
um we are probably minutes away from
impeachment
minutes minutes minutes to go from
impeachment
down to the last 16 we need 217 to do
the two vacant seats
um and the question is did the white
house receive those
and tell the dod not to provide the
national guard
to tell dhs not to provide anything what
happened in terms of the white house's
knowledge about what the expectations
were right
and then after the violence occurred
uh what happened within the white house
about
um what direction to go 11 to go
allowing the national guard to go we
know governor larry hogan from maryland
said we are down to just
10 votes to go 10 votes to go
and donald trump will be impeached a
second time it's never happened
uh it is humiliating there are probably
four four
strong impeachment cases against trump
that could have been brought
um and we have 10 votes to go before
donald trump will be impeached for a
second time
the only surprise is that he wasn't
impeached more
says techno gogo techno go via twitch
that's absolutely right
that's absolutely right now come on guys
again people are saying what do you mean
the first impeachment failed
no the house impeaches
the senate decides guilt or innocence
trump was impeached once by the house
and he's about to be impeached a second
time
trump lost both popular votes trump will
be impeached twice
he then lost the house during the
midterms and then lost the senate and
the white house
in 2020. wow wow nine votes to go
only nine votes to go
a lot of people asking me to legalize
ranch i'm open to that i'm more of a
uh parmesan peppercorn guy but you know
i'm fine with ranch as well thank you
for your hard work and
ever educating everyone you reach i
appreciate that
david there are reports of massive
discount dumps all across your website
very worrying i know i know
what's more important massive vaccine
rollout or mass deprogramming of
trumpists
that is a that is a sophie's choice i
i'd have to think about that
i would really have to think about that
is it wrong to have told someone that
claimed to be from germany that they
were lying because they said trump
isn't like hitler i feel like i have a
point
i don't even understand the question
dave it's sick in veg with kovid right
now you're stream keeping me entertained
every day thoughts on pineapple on pizza
you know when i when i used to eat pork
i liked pineapple on pizza because i
would love like a canadian bacon and
pineapple pizza
since i've stopped eating pork i find
little use for pineapple
i find it really only works with
canadian bacon
um yeah here is to looking forward to
hearing about
policy discussions and less about
trump's shameful antics i'm hopeful for
a unified usa
but not naive to believe it will happen
as soon as most of us would like
breaking trump just filed for
unemployment right
we are six votes away six votes
away five votes away
from the impeachment number two of
donald trump
four votes away let's listen three votes
to the house managers to identify
the witnesses who are most likely to
have the relevant information because
in the votes to go they will unlike last
time they will not
know uh the universe of people that has
information about what the president
knew and when he knew it
um but i would expect there to be voting
on witnesses and there will probably be
a few witnesses and there'll be
depositions for the witnesses
i i don't i wouldn't anticipate this one
vote to go
nine republicans and there it is donald
john trump has been impeached
uh donald trump has become the first
president in the history of the united
states
and my friend michael steele former
chairman of the rep
and uh with 220 votes 221 the numbers
continue
there has never been a president
impeached twice
until 15 seconds ago or conscious he
he lays it out he says this vote's not a
victory it isn't a victory for my party
it isn't a victory for the democrats
uh it isn't the victory the democrats
might think it is i'm not sure it's a
victory for our country but it is a call
to action
for us to reflect on these events and
seek ways to right uh okay
let's put together let's put together a
tweet real quick here
donald trump
has now been impeached twice
lost the popular vote twice
lost the house for republicans
in 2018 lost the senate for
republicans in 2020 and made himself
a one-term president
winning
beautiful beautiful donald trump
has been impeached peach president
donald j
trump republican house member
congressman meyer
what do you think when you see them
wrestling so publicly with this but
coming out
10 republicans 10 republicans have voted
in favor
of the impeachment of donald trump there
are just
11 votes to go and then we will hear
uh the ruling from the chair very
very important stuff going on the the
last votes coming in
miss jayapal pursuant to house of
resolution eight i rise to inform the
house that ms jayapal
will vote eye on house resolution 24.
if you're just joining us donald trump
has been impeached for a second
time for a second time
the trial
is not going to take place until joe
biden is president
a conviction if it were to happen would
be a retroactive
conviction trump will be gone by the
time the trial
takes place more impeachments than
terms says bay photo yes that's
absolutely right
a david that discount code wow
i know it's it's it is shocking
with little knowledge about impeachment
what does this mean exactly will he have
to leave office before biden's
inauguration
no there isn't even going to be a trial
until joe biden is president
so the answer to that is no i can see a
lot of people
very excited by what's going on uh
13 additional people have grabbed twitch
subscriptions which puts us at 183
and then another 14 people
have signed up on my website which puts
us at 197.
it is a uh it's an incredible day we
have never had a president
impeach two times and we do today 10
republicans
abandoning their party uh rightfully so
and voting for the impeachment of donald
trump a total of 229 members of the
house have voted for
the impeachment of donald trump there
are just nine votes left to be cast
and then we will soon hear an
announcement from the house of
representatives
uh about the results but donald trump
has indeed
been impeached donald trump has been
impeached
i read that impeachment after he's out
of office is not constitutional is that
correct
that is not my understanding nice to see
republican
yay votes in double figures yes it is
canadian hear best of luck to southern
neighbors to recover from this shocked
that 200 republicans overlook
last week it's disgusting
it is absolutely and completely
disgusting
uh oh hold on i'm told that we have hit
our goal
we have hit our goal ladies and
gentlemen at the stroke of donald
trump's second impeachment
the david pakman show youtube channel
has reached
1.25 million subscribers
1.25 million subscribers you know
our first month
on youtube we had four
subscribers our first month on youtube
we had four subscribers
and in the last hour we've gained two
thousand
think about that think about that uh
that is uh it is it's an unbelievable
number
um and so now on to twitch uh we are
still
we are still heading in the direction of
our first hundred thousand
on twitch which uh hopefully will come
this year if it doesn't we're doing
something very very wrong
we are down to just seven more
votes until we will have final numbers
for the second impeachment of donald
trump
the sec six more votes 230
voting in favor of impeachment and soon
we will get that
a final roll call number uh from the
speaker
which is which is just wild eric says
congrats on 1.25 million thanks for
great content staying tuned
staying tuned on the 20th yes
will trump is rage or riot tonight maybe
it's so hard to know what they're going
to do
the 10 republicans used dominion right
yeah they need a recount don't they we
just have
five votes left to be cast five votes
left to be cast
and then that will be it
but we already have that number uh 231
voting to impeach means
trump is impeached despite the posturing
how is it not to the republicans
political advantage to get trump out of
the way
enormous for the 1.25 um
i mean i i think that for a lot of them
they have the pulse
uh on their constituencies and it's not
abundantly clear that uh
that they should abandon trump i think
it's that simple
i believe many of us take with a heavy
heart
where are we hearing that audio from
seems like just background noise let's
listen here he's the president
and and josh hawley and and ted cruz
and and jim jordan and some of the other
folks running around the halls of the
congress now talking about unity
we have a question can trump still
resign of course he can resign at any
time
anytime he can resign um i i don't
imagine that he will
but at absolutely any time he would be
able to resign
uh hold on a second here
do we have trolls that need to be banned
in the chat it's just so annoying
oh no i think we're okay i think we're
okay right now
um five votes still to go five votes
still to go just cast them my friends
cast the votes heard the one who has a
crush on you is
megan the stallion whap
jesus i don't even know what that is
that sounds like something the kids
these days or ben shapiro would be
talking about i don't even know
a second trump impeachment is only the
cherry on top to the 1.25 million
subscribers
the rest of it was the treliches
incredible job keep it up dave
couldn't say it better myself could not
possibly say it better myself
uh okay
good stuff in the house let's see what
the senate does content
mark schwartz wanting spanish content
for his parents
we are still waiting on five final votes
i don't know what's keeping them
probably grandstanding five may there
could be five individuals
there's probably more than five but at
least five individuals who
um want want to uh
make themselves seem really really
important did i see levy rosman won his
chess match today honestly i didn't know
he had a chess match today who was it
against can anybody tell me
who was who is it against was it against
eric rosen
versus james canty i don't know who that
is
okay good good for levy that's fantastic
what will mcconnell do will there be
enough to convict don't know yet
don't know yet david it is my greatest
pleasure to inform you
that you will be inducted into the bd
boys
congratulations i have i don't know what
the hell that is
is that good or bad sounds questionable
the republicans that voted yes shouldn't
win any favor for this you don't get to
beat someone half to death and then get
praised for not going all the way
yeah it's like saying uh it's like
taking
all of someone's food and then giving
them a granola bar and saying
look who else is giving you food right
now well but yeah you took all their
food
that doesn't really make sense uh when
will the senate vote well before
there's gonna be a trial and then the
senate will vote and the trial isn't
even expected to be
until joe biden is uh president you have
to wonder how many of his friends will
wise up to trump's distorted reality or
continue to drink the kool-aid congrats
on the 1.25 million
absolutely absolutely uh
you know the the really historic event
here is trump being impeached a second
time
but there's a lot of people in the chat
that seem to be more compelled by
1.25 million youtube subscribers
and i have to tell you i don't disagree
completely
what does a second impeachment do per my
wife well nothing
i mean listen here's the thing about
impeachment it is a responsibility if
the president does something impeachable
you impeach that's it
it doesn't matter if there's seven days
to go uh it doesn't matter
you know no none of it matters let's
listen to what's happening here now
the violent mob who tore down the
american flag oh this was earlier sorry
okay um yeah we're just waiting still
waiting on five votes
still waiting on five votes david the
epoch times is advertising on your
channel now can you block them
i'm not aware of any way to block them
we have no control over youtube
advertisers
and they're not advertising on my
channel
specifically they're just doing news and
politics okay
david i'm killing it on chess.com lately
let's play okay
david could you go back to my missed
super chat all right let me try here
richard k david would strongly recommend
you have sam harris on the program again
check out his recent podcast episode
related to the attack on the capitol
uh yeah i actually i sent sam an email
two weeks ago and i haven't heard back
sam harris is ghosting me
or my email went to spam or he's too
busy
but i would be glad to have him back on
the first interview
with sam harris was a good interview it
doesn't mean we agreed on everything and
in fact we didn't
but i would be glad to have him again
and uh he's welcome
he's welcome anytime for sure how did he
get out of his first impeachment well
the senate just didn't didn't convict
wendy says david you earned the 1250 000
subscribers
congratulations thank you wendy i
appreciate that
they need two-thirds to convict right
yes you need two-thirds to convict in
the senate that is exactly right
two-thirds is the required number to
convict in the senate
we are stuck waiting for five more
votes let's see if there's any tweets
about that
impeachment five votes
hold out maybe i'll find something no
maybe if i get rid of the word hold out
five votes to go more impeachment than
terms oh
have all members voted now nancy pelosi
does any member wish to change a vote
we should be seeing trump absolutely
lose his [ __ ] on twitter right now
but because he's banned from twitter we
don't have that privilege no we can't
though
it is what it is
okay looks like we're getting close here
people did not vote and i guess that's
right
claire we're listening in uh we heard
the speaker ask if all the votes are in
the vote count currently stands at
231 votes to impeach donald trump 197.
again
i know go ahead does the network know
claire you're
you're mike's open we're on the air um
we heard the speaker
um ask if every vote was in it sounds
like she's getting close to announcing
the vote total
no is the network now there we go
there's another one we're in my
microphone
claire you're on the air oh that's just
the best
okay um they said they were letting me
go
the eyes are 232. the nays are 197.
the resolution is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the
table congratulations
i think this is swalwell down here he
follows us good guy
speaker nancy pelosi announcing the vote
in the house
232 members of congress voting to
impeach donald trump donald trump has
been impeached
a second time becoming the first
president the chair announces that
pursuant to section 3a
of house resolution 41. the house
resolution 40 is hereby adopted
trump impeached for the second time
[Applause]
the chair announces the speaker's
appointment
pursuant to clause 11 of rule 10 clause
11 of rule 1
and order in in the order the following
of the house of january 4th 2021
of the following members of the house to
the permanent select committee on
intelligence
mr chef of california chair mr nunes
okay
a lot going on here as you can see
donald trump has been impeached a second
time we're waiting and watching along
with all of you
um in the meantime i want to bring in a
a special guest of this broadcast
freshman democratic congresswoman corey
bush of missouri joins us
congresswoman um your thoughts about
this vote this morning what it means and
whether things will change
pursuant to section 5a
1b of house resolution 8 the
and it needed to happen now um we could
not wait around to see how people
thought what people thought what will
the senate do
our job as the house of representatives
the white supremacist in chief that's
who he has been
that has been okay with him and we saw
it on full display january the 6th and
we're hearing
we will see even more coming up over the
next week
and so we had to make this decision
today i was
proud to cast my vote
to be a part of impeaching donald j
trump
what impact does it have in your view
in terms of prevention okay so donald
trump
has been impeached donald trump has been
impeached a second time it is over
it is over and unfortunately we are
unable to see
what donald trump is saying because as
you can see
donald trump's twitter account has
indeed been
suspended it has indeed been suspended
yeah i don't know what the vavuzela
sound was
but uh it is what it is as they say
so that's going to do it for me i
appreciate everybody who joined me we
have a major production day because of
what we we have to cover tomorrow
trump impeached a second time we will
have analysis we will have reaction we
will have everything okay
um really appreciate everybody who
joined me make sure you're following me
on twitch
make sure you've subscribed on youtube
it's all free costs nothing
and we'll see everybody tomorrow